from the time Harry was living in that
tiny closet under the stairs to the time
he was finding Horcruxes in the woods
we have been rooting for Harry Hermione
and Ron but reading the stories and
watching the movies as a child is much
different than experiencing these same
stories as an adult here are 10 things
kids don't understand in Harry Potter
wizard sure do love their house elves
poor Dobby he is so loving optimistic
and traumatised this little house elf
wants so desperately to help Harry but
he's a bit clumsy and unaware that noise
travels he has some of the funniest
lines in the film but he's so used to
being abused by his owners that he hurts
himself when he feels like he has done
something wrong how sad at first
Hermione seemed to be the only one who
had a problem with how elves were being
treated in the magical world everyone
else just sort of went along with it do
they not teach the history of the world
at Hogwarts
Hermione seems to be the only one who
reads in these stories Dobby the
house-elf
is one of the most honest and loyal
characters in the whole series he comes
from a long line of enslaved house elves
because of this he doesn't want too much
freedom just the little taste he caught
from Harry's sock was enough he went on
to work in the kitchen at Hogwarts for a
tiny wage and only had one day off a
month and all kids everywhere were just
fine with it it's not until adulthood
that you realize how messed up this
whole situation is Hogwarts the school
of detrimental studies very few parents
would ever consider sending their
children to a school with moving
staircases fatal screaming Mandrake's
flying broomsticks enormous serpents oh
and an evil wizard who is trying to rule
the world what a lovely story for
children seriously all the parents were
cool with this a kid actually passed
away the last time the Chamber of
Secrets was opened while this might
sound scary to most young kids don't
truly understand what this entails but
parents who watch the films and read the
books are rightfully horrified during
these brushes with the grim reaper it
should have been updating sign when Ron
Weasley's mom told Harry to run at full
speed into a brick
at a platform 9 and 3/4 and while the
moving staircases are kind of awesome
one has to wonder how many students fell
from great heights after a small misstep
all that's protecting though young
wizards and witches from the fatal
scream of the Mandrake are those little
earmuffs no one seems concerned about
kids plummeting to the ground during a
lively Quidditch game if hogwarts were a
real place all of the professor's would
have been arrested for child
endangerment if the ministry quite a bit
of grief a few years ago perhaps this
will show you why wherefore art thou
sold it's not bad enough that
practically all of the students at
hogwarts are potentially fighting just
to stay alive there's a major deterrent
for breaking the laws of the Wizarding
World the biggest sanction is not jail
or even capital punishment if you commit
a big enough crime your soul will
literally get sucked out of your body
the Dementors kiss these terrifying
nightmare fodder ghosts like banshee
creatures are the police force yep if
you commit a serious crime they'll eat
your soul leaving you to live out the
rest of your days as an empty shell of a
wizard they try to eat Harry soul -
yikes who saw these things and thought
sure let's put these abominations in
charge of the Law & Order of the land
although the ministry is supposed to
control their actions they seem to be
more interested in listening to the Dark
Lord's orders kids and adults are
rightfully scared out of their wit's by
these Dementors but adults can really
see just how disturbing this whole
concept is commit a crime and lose the
very thing that makes you you so far
slavery perilous living situations and
torture are all present in the Harry
Potter world and considering that these
books are meant for children it's no
surprise that parents are raising
eyebrows
Dumbledore's questionable hiring methods
we have a lot of questions about the
qualifications and mental competence of
the professors at Hogwarts from
werewolves to malignant narcissists -
totally blithering nincompoops
it's as if Hogwarts scrapes the bottom
of the barrel when picking its faculty
it seems that Dumbledore in the school
board will let just about anybody be in
charge of a classroom full of young
helpless and innocent students they're
teaching these kids how to cast
dangerous
spells and wield weapons without so much
as a background check what does that
application and hiring process look like
from the looks of things Dumbledore has
a hard time filling in the defense
against dark arts position so whenever
he finds himself a newly interested
teacher he asks them the least amount of
questions after all it's a well-known
fact that professors who teach this
subject don't always make it through the
year so whenever Dumbledore gets a
contestant he basically just says
fantastic
you're hired of course all kids have
wondered from time to time if one of
their teachers was borderline unstable
but this takes it to a whole new level
Mustard's spouse that you can attempt in
your JCS daydreams slipping people
potions like it's no big deal
in the normal society in which we
muggles live it's considered highly
illegal to slip something into someone
else's drink but it looks like there are
very different set of rules in the Harry
Potter world Hogwarts is a magical place
however some of the students are being
taught how to brew potions that will
make someone fall in love with them in
fact
the Wizarding World acts like love
potions aren't a big deal so what if
your crush doesn't like you back there's
a potion for that Fred and George
Weasley once said that love potions are
one of the most popular items that they
sell so we've got a bunch of pubescent
teenagers with hormones coursing through
their veins and they have access to a
potion that destroys inhibitions reason
and free will we're surprised Hogwarts
didn't turn into a debauchery love
dungeon in the books
JK Rowling writes that anyone who has
children under the spell of a love
potion is doomed
you think talk about the worst hangover
of all time as an adult you realize the
implications of this irresponsible
potion and it's all just too creepy
here you go teenage Hermione now don't
destroy the universe it's no wonder
Hermione is so smart and well-educated
she was given a time Turner by
Dumbledore so she could study more now
most children in adults don't know much
about the concept of time travel but the
adults know enough to ask a few
important questions the most obvious
question is this why would you trust a
teenager with such a complicated gadget
that is capable of so much chaos was
Dumbledore
not concerned at all that Hermione would
rip an irreparable hole in the fabric of
time and space her prefrontal cortex in
her brain is still developing at her age
that's the part of the brain responsible
for impulse control not a wise idea
Dumbledore but a necessary one
nonetheless when he gives her at the
time Turner he warns Hermione not to let
her past self see her
apparently witches and wizards who meet
themselves during a time jump often go
completely bonkers imagine running into
your future self that's enough to jumble
anyone's brains
oddly enough Dumbledore was totally okay
with risking Hermione as sanity and the
feet of the universe just so she could
get good grades this sort of behavior is
totally acceptable at Hogwarts however
it's no secret that Dumbledore had
ulterior motives classism and race the
wizards and witches at Hogwarts are
dealing with major cases of classism and
racism we agree that it's important for
kids to learn to recognize this type of
appalling behavior but when you watch
the films and read the books as an adult
these themes hold a much heavier weight
this is because we are aware of the
severe consequences of this type of
thinking kids don't fully grasp that
racism can cause a lot of harm and end
up violating people's rights that's what
makes Voldemort particularly scary to
adults
the dude led a movement to cause a fight
between the pureblood witches and
wizards and muggle-borns and while some
kids are too young to understand how
devastating this kind of movement can be
adults easily recognize it the world has
not forgotten what happened in World War
one which is why we don't take racism
lightly at first glance Voldemort might
come off as a fictional character but
when put under the scope he's a spitting
image of an evil dictator who must not
be named Fulda Mort encourages attacks
on muggles and tries to assert pureblood
supremacy and then there are the
classist and racist themes surrounding
the house elves pretty dark for a kid's
story right the Weasley twin conundrum
the Weasley twins are responsible for
most of the rebellious pranks at
Hogwarts at the surface level they seem
like your typical older brothers they
pick on their kin like any normal
sibling right
uh wrong let's just look at all of the
horrible priests they played on poor Ron
one of the most psychologically damaging
pranks was played on Ron when he was
just three years old Ron was doing
normal toddler things like accidentally
breaking his brother Fred's broomstick
so what does Fred do he emotionally
scars Ron for life apparently he turned
Ron's teddy bear into a big hairy spider
as fiebag so one minute little Ron is
snuggling up to his teddy bear for
comfort and the next minute he realizes
he's holding a giant spider with hairy
legs that caused Ron to have a lifelong
phobia of spiders not cool Fred and then
there was the time they gave Ron an acid
puff that burned a hole in his tongue
that's something only a psychopath would
do to a child while these twins helped
Ron Harry and Hermione out from time to
time they don't always have their best
intentions at heart hidden innuendos
when you're dealing with a story about
teenagers it's best to be careful what
you say but JK Rowling put a lot of
innuendos in the book that kids probably
don't understand let's start with
Moaning Myrtle she's The Melancholy
poltergeist who hangs out in the
bathroom sure she's sad and lonely but
that's no excuse for her inappropriate
behavior it seems Myrtle likes to play
peeping tom on any of the young boys who
visit her bathrooms she spied on both
Cedric and Harry she didn't even seem to
feel ashamed about it and then there's
her name interesting choice of words but
these stories are absolutely littered
with double entendres and hidden
innuendos there was the time that Ron
was asking about that unexpected planet
the professor told him that it was
Uranus then Ron asked if he could look
at Uranus too it also seems that ones
represent another part of the human
anatomy this is evident when Cedric is
bragging about the size of his wand he
boasts that it is 12 and a quarter
inches long and that he just polished it
last night which is um highly
inappropriate
what's Dumbledore steel Dumbledore seems
like a loving caring headmaster but he
knowingly puts young Harry in a lot of
danger it's kind of disturbing that
you're Dumbledore sons young Harry to
try and defeat powerful beasts and the
latest version of
he-who-must-not-be-named looper has even
gone so far as to call Dumbledore a
Machiavellian sociopath some would argue
that Dumbledore is just grooming Harry
to become the most powerful wizard in
the world so he can save everyone from
Voldemort but he is super irresponsible
considering Harry's age and abilities he
hires crazy incompetent and downright
dangerous professors this action alone
in dangers all of his students at
Hogwarts but then he subjects Harry to
scenarios that involved torture exposes
him to debilitating cruelty and shows
him things no child should ever see
we're not sure if Dumbledore is a
sociopath or just way too old to be in
charge of children but most parents
would probably have a big problem with
his methods Dumbledore is either
incredibly cruel or incredibly dedicated
to saving the Wizarding World either way
Dumbledore did the best he could and
ended up grooming Harry for his destiny
he even sacrificed himself to ensure
that the Boy Who Lived would live once
more although Dumbledore might get a bad
rep we can't help but love him as much
as he loves lemon drops
what are some other adult themes you
noticed in Harry Potter tell us in the
comments below thanks for watching the
things don't forget to subscribe like
this video and hit that notification
bell to be the first to see our newest
videos see you next time
[Music]